[Music]
bye
[Music]
i used to obsess over productivity i
used to set my alarm for 4 a.m just so i
could squeeze in a morning workout
answer emails write a youtube script
batch prep breakfast for the kids or do
all of these things at once before
everyone else woke up and going to bed
just thinking about that early morning
set me up to fail it drove up my
cortisol it increased my anxiety it
perpetuated a cycle of insomnia that
ultimately ruined my health and my
happiness and while my anxiety disorder
warranted medication and a lot of
therapy doing this one thing made a huge
difference in my day i stopped setting
an alarm to wake up let's be real aren't
kids the best
alarms money can't buy us moms wake up
from the faintest little squeak from our
littles and i feel so much more of a
natural drive to get out of bed when
they're calling my name versus when my
iphone is barking obnoxiously to do some
arbitrary to-do lists that i made up
myself now i realize it's a privilege
and a luxury for me to be able to modify
my day to meet my own mental health
needs but letting go of the need to
utilize every single moment of the day
for productivity has ironically made me
even more productive it's definitely
improved my sleep now it's not perfect
but here's how i start my day also a big
reminder that this is my morning not
yours so do not attempt to copy it in
any way as always please speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
needs and a big thank you to copilot for
sponsoring today's video all right let's
get into my day so on weekday mornings
my hubs takes the kids while i go and
get a quick workout in now as part of my
sibo protocol i start with a scoop of
partially hydrolyzed guar gum aka sun
fiber which is a prebiotic fiber
supplement that helps to gently improve
motility during sibo recovery now as you
can see this is not my home gym i'm
actually at the cottage camping out with
the kids during omicron so i don't have
all of my regular gear but i can still
get a solid workout in thanks to
co-pilot so co-pilot is a one-on-one
fitness and nutrition experience where
you fill out a survey they match you
with a coach and you set up your fitness
goals and plan
now whenever you work out the system
will automatically track your sets your
pacing and your range of motion and your
coach will be with you to guide you
through
they can work within whatever equipment
and space you have and whatever time you
have available so it's really ideal for
folks with chaotic schedules like me or
when i'm traveling and not with all of
my gear at home i've been working with
darian who is an actual real person that
i've actually met virtually to discuss
my goals and my fitness level and my
time commitment she then creates real
video workouts uniquely for me at
scheduled times in the week and she can
track my activity and then send lots of
tips videos for form and of course
motivation through the app i literally
have all of the benefits of in-person
training working with darien but with
way more convenience safety and of
course a more reasonable price i really
can't imagine a reason to ever go back
so if you want to check out co-pilot
yourself check out my link in the
description to get 20 off of your own
co-pilot experience plus a 14-day free
trial
[Music]
so i don't usually make special
breakfast like this usually just piece
together random things to make a
relatively balanced meal for myself but
um
about twice a week i try to do some like
batch breakfast things for the kiddos
that way since i am waking up basically
at the same time that they are when they
are already hangry and
you know looking for breakfast i just
kind of pull it out of the fridge so
that way when they wake up early and i'm
basically waking up at the same time
i've already got something in the fridge
that i can just re-warm and throw on the
table so this is going to be their
breakfast tomorrow or second breakfast
for them
[Music]
the kids are playing hand go seek and i
think
i finally got a good batch
[Music]
okay so i've come up here to hide
because it's my work hour right now
and i gotta make use of it but first
coffee
essential for work breakfast which i've
got all the things and i took my
supplements so there's a lot there so
let's break it all down step one i got
my soy milk latte in the best mug of all
time right here as you guys know coffee
is a real ritual for me so i really
really like to sit down sip and savor it
um in peace rather than like chugging it
down while i'm like wrangling two
children so that's why i'm hiding up
here to enjoy this little
slice
of heaven it is my favorite part of the
day and it's something that i actually
look forward to
literally as soon as the cup is empty so
and if you're wondering why i don't just
have another one
it's because it's just not good for my
my anxiety and my sleep probably any
coffee is not good for my anxiety and
sleep but you know i also need to
function so there's that next we've got
breakfast
so
i got my pancakes
um whole grain pancakes with some
blueberries and hemp hearts in there and
i also mashed up some ripe banana which
obviously the box of pancake mix does
not call for but it just adds natural
sweetness so
this way i find the kids can even eat
them just like as a handheld snack on
the go and they don't actually even need
extra maple syrup necessarily i actually
ran out of maple syrup i know canadian
faux pas
so i've topped mine with some full fat
greek yogurt and some honey
and some more hemp hearts and some more
blooms take a look at that
and
because i'm trying to you know space out
my meals here
um
i'm not done so i've got a bowl of
cottage cheese i love cottage cheese
it's one of my favorite kind of
sources of protein more blueberries
because that's the last of the fruit
that we have in the house before i go
grocery shopping tomorrow and i like a
little crunch so
i have life cereal mmm which is one of
my current new favorites
so good and in case i'm still hungry
after all that i grabbed a banana might
not need it but i just prefer to have
all the things up here so i don't need
to go back down there and then
you know there's a whole mommyitis
situation happening uh just trying to
get myself back up here
and step three my supplements if you
guys have been following my sibo saga
journey
you know that there are a lot of
supplements involved
and just based on where i'm at right now
i am taking a variety of things mainly
for my digestion so yeah i've gotten
real good at taking a lot of pills uh in
one gulp i know it's a strange talent
but i'm proud of it and i do not like to
rush this part of my morning but i also
need to seriously utilize it for work so
i'm going to get to it somehow my
coffee's already cold i don't know how
that happens
[Music]
loki
honey
oh mom that was a squirter
that's what she said honey on pancakes
is good especially blueberries it has a
match made in
breakfast heaven
okay now is the really super boring part
of my day
i basically just stare at a screen for
an hour um but i'm trying to edit a few
scripts to record when i get home next
week
and also to coordinate with my team
on today's youtube video and
tick tock video but also i just remember
something i need
in my instacart order so i'm going to do
that before i forget because this is how
my brain works got to add bread
how do i forget these things honestly oh
my goodness
do you have a sourdough
done
we're in good shape
[Music]
also wasn't planning on this being part
of my morning routine video but honestly
it's a very important part of my morning
routine i have to go use the washroom so
excuse me
does anyone else feel like kind of
anxious
if they don't go
when they normally go because i feel
like i get up in my head and we know how
connected the brain is to the gut and
then it like
makes me constipated for the day like
it's a self-fulfilling prophecy right
that's the way anxiety works so
yeah i'm very happy that nature is
calling so i'm gonna go
answer the call oh man
i am
kind of distracted by just like the
beautiful snow and that bright white
light outside it is
so
mesmerizing and distracting honestly and
i have to be honest i was very hesitant
to come up north because you know
i was like
i'm going to be so lonely
i don't have
family help that i love it's going to be
so cold
so much work with kids i don't have the
great setup that i have at home for life
or for work or just the comforts of home
so yeah i put up a real
fight
about it with my hubby but honestly this
is really typical anxious abby
thoughts and behaviors and i acknowledge
that i am really routine oriented and
it's very hard for me to switch up that
routine even if i know it's potentially
better for my mental health or my
physical health just to try like i
described it to my husband as kind of
having almost like a moment of panic
any time somebody asks me to
you know change up my routine or my plan
at a moment's notice your girl is
not so spontaneous but yeah this is
typical perfectionist type a behavior
and it definitely played a role in my
past ed so yeah if you guys can relate
to this mentality definitely leave me a
comment below it's something i still
struggle with today but i'm definitely
working on
challenging myself a little bit outside
my comfort zone hence
why i'm here anyway i'm justifying
procrastinating right now because this
is also
kind of work
um but i also have deadlines that i have
to meet so i am going to get back to my
writing before i go hang out with the
kids
[Music]
okay so i've got about 30 minutes left
in my little work morning here and i
have to take a quick call with my team
so it's so beautiful outside it's
actually quite mild this morning so i
figured i would take it on a little bit
of a walk so for my southern followers
welcome to canada this is going to be
the most canadian episode of abby's
kitchen ever made
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it is so nice to get outside um i
haven't been able to do this every day
up here because there have been some
brutally
cold days where we just have not left
the house but the daylight is so so good
for me um there's research to suggest
that it helps to boost serotonin levels
and the juxtaposition against the
darkness at night helps with melatonin
and therefore sleep so i do sleep quite
well up here partially because it's so
quiet especially compared to the city
and also i think the juxtaposition
between the brightness of day and the
darkness of night is really good for my
hormones so yeah i am mindful of the
time though it's gonna take me a good
like 20 minutes to take all this gear
back off so i'm going to get to it so
that's my morning routine
and honestly i don't feel like it's any
less productive than my morning routine
when i was purposefully waking up at 4
am to do it all because i just feel less
dead inside honestly more hours in the
day to be productive is not really
valuable when you spend most of those
hours just like staring at a wall in
misery or like scrolling through tick
tock or if you burn out in the process
so here's to 2022
without burnout and on that note it is
officially noon so i'm tagging in for
parenting duties gotta get my little one
down for a nap but a big thank you to
copilot for sponsoring this video if you
liked it be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below on other
topics you guys want to see me vlog
about subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]
you